Let's look at projective transformation.
In a projective transformation, what we
are interested in is taking an image and
warping it in this manner.
So basically,
a projective transformation is
a combination of an affine
transformation we've looked at, but
added to that, a projective warp.
Properties of that form
of transformation is.
The origin does not again
necessarily map to the origin.
You can see that this
could've transformed or
move translated over to this point.
But the line are still straight lines,
right?
Lines map to straight lines here.
But now parallel lines do not
necessarily remain parallel.
An example of this you may actually see.
That for example, if t and h,
if they were parallel here,
they're no longer parallel if I was
to draw an h here and a t here.
Let's just do that.
And they would actually
intersect somewhere.
While t and h, unlikely to intersect.
And of course ratios are not
preserved in this one either.
Here, of course, we have.
What do you think?
Nine parameters?
Nah.
Remember,
I always said this
will convert back to 1.
So in essence, we have 8 parameters.
Which basically means we
have 8 degree of freedom.